[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
CASPER KLYNGE: Hello.
[LAUGHTER]
RASMUS GREVE: Welcome.
Thank you for coming.
I guess we can take a seat
or something like that.
CASPER KLYNGE: Sure.
RASMUS GREVE: We
can also stand up.
I don't really
have a preference.
Welcome here today,
your "Tech-cellency,"
if I'm allowed to call you that.
I mean, I've been in talks
with you for a little while.
I am super, super
excited about you
coming today and talking
to us, and telling us
about what you do.
But before we begin, since--
I've been at Google
for a very long time,
but I also know people
that work in the embassies
and in diplomacy, and that's
a lot of different approach
to things-- can you
please just tell me
about your first
meeting with Google
in this capacity
as an ambassador?
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
Well, first of all, thanks
for hosting me today.
And thanks, also,
for listening in.
Yeah, I'm a career
diplomat so, you know,
normally this is the kind
of gear that you wear,
and we're here because of
the UN General Assembly.
So suits and,
actually, ties is sort
of part of the uniform today.
But when I arrived in
Silicon Valley 12 months ago,
one of the first meetings
we had was actually
in Mountain View with
the Google headquarters.
And it was a clash of
two different cultures
and, to some extent, a
clash of civilizations.
Because, together with
my deputy, we went there,
more or less, dressed like this.
And our counterpart came out
in flip-flops and short shorts,
and I think an old
Metallica t-shirt.
And we actually have a
fantastic picture where we're
standing next to each other.
And for me, this
was the wake-up call
that we actually need
a dialogue, the two
different worlds.
And after that, we also went
out to buy a lot of jeans
and a lot of white sneakers.
And now the uniform
is different,
and we also, in that area, are
a little bit different than what
diplomats are normally like.
RASMUS GREVE: Yeah.
I did hear about you saying
that you'd made really
poor financial decisions.
[LAUGHTER]
CASPER KLYNGE: I have too
many suits, basically, now.
[LAUGHTER]
RASMUS GREVE: So you're the
world's first tech ambassador
appointed by a country.
Can you explain to the
audience a little bit more
about what a tech
ambassador does,
and the whole idea behind it?
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah, sure.
Well, if we go back a
year or so and, perhaps,
one and a half years ago,
there was an innovation process
inside the Danish government
and inside the Foreign Ministry,
where we looked a
little bit on trends
and how to bring, basically,
the Foreign Ministry
into the 21st century.
And some very talented
younger colleagues came up
with a number of
different ideas.
And one of them was to
appoint a tech ambassador.
And the reason for this are
two trends, if we look at it.
One being that we think
technolo-- and probably,
I don't have to convince
anybody in this room,
or anybody watching in--
that technology is going to
be one of the main drivers
for global development.
It's going to have a
lot of positive effects,
but it might also have a couple
of challenges along the way.
In other words, technology
will be defining the winners
and losers of tomorrow,
but it will also
define some of the
foreign policy,
or international
relations, of this world.
Also, balance of
power, where I think
things like machine learning,
artificial intelligence,
perhaps even IoT, is
going to be as important
as conventional weapons,
or even nuclear weapons.
So the mindset of
looking at technology
from a foreign
policy point of view
goes to the core
of this initiative.
And the other trend, or
the other main reason
why we did this was, of course--
and this one, I
know I don't have
to convince anybody about
sitting here today--
is that some of the big
technology companies,
not least in the US, are
becoming very, very big, very
influential, not least
with the platforms
that you guys have developed
and built and utilize.
But we also see, increasingly,
that companies are perhaps
using that platform
power also to begin
influencing policies, and
the direction of this world.
So we, basically-- or
the Danish government
basically decided that
instead of just watching
the future pass by
outside the windows,
we wanted to actually
begin treating
the industry and technology
and digitalization
as a foreign policy priority.
And by creating this
first-ever tech representation,
and begin dealing
with these issues,
to seek to influence the
direction despite being a very
small country.
RASMUS GREVE: And what
would a company like Google
have to gain by engaging and
meeting with a tech ambassador?
CASPER KLYNGE: I think
you have a few more
users than the size of
the Danish population.
But I think the basic
idea behind this
is actually that we
can't do it alone.
I think government is
always trailing behind
on new technologies.
We don't necessarily get
it right on regulations,
on legislation.
Our policies are
being challenged
because of the fast pace
of these new technologies.
And whether you call
it the digital age
or the fourth
Industrial Revolution,
it doesn't really matter.
Because I think the gap is
widening on our ability,
as governments, or as
international organizations,
to actually cope
with the future.
But I don't think
that companies are
able to do it alone, either.
And of course, we
might discuss a couple
of examples over the
last couple of months,
or the last year or so.
But I think the point here
is that we need each other.
We need to work closer
together than we have, perhaps,
in the past.
And we need to find
joint solutions
on some of the big issues,
both global issues,
but also national issues.
So this is basically a
very big, warm, fuzzy hug
from the Danish government
to the tech industry.
But also a subtle way of saying,
we need to come closer together
and we need to find,
together, solutions
to some of the big issues
that we are faced with, also
on a global level.
RASMUS GREVE: Yeah.
And as we talked about, there's
one part where you're always
saying, oh, governments
are trailing behind.
And digitalization for
governments and all that.
But tech companies,
as well, need
to also be really
at a level of how
governments are thinking about
protecting their inhabitants.
And not only
protecting, but also
offering them
opportunities, and not
letting them get caught behind
in this global tech revolution
that we're seeing.
Let's just call it the
fourth Industrial Revolution.
I think that's a
nice term for it.
Because there are so many things
that are happening out there.
And just to dial it back a
little bit-- because we start
out-- we always talk
about it like it's
Denmark and, full disclosure,
I am from Denmark.
I've been living
here for eight years,
but I still have
a very big stake
in thinking how interesting
this is, you know?
So maybe you could explain
to the world, why Denmark?
Such a small little country
on the northern tip of Europe,
with the population size
of Colorado, for Americans.
Why is it Denmark, of all
countries, that start--
that becomes the first to
appoint a tech ambassador,
and give them the mandate,
you, to go out there and try
and engage with us?
CASPER KLYNGE: Well, I think
there are three reasons why
we came up with this.
First of all, we had
some extremely talented
younger colleagues, who saw this
and who came up with the idea,
and who were able to convince
the senior management back
home that we needed to
go in this direction.
The other reason is,
of course, that we
have a little bit of street
cred on digitalization
because we are a
very digital country.
Whether you look at UN
assessments or European Union
assessments, we
normally come out
at the top of these
assessments, in terms
of public digitalization.
You probably know that
90% of all communications
between the government
and citizens in Denmark
are, today, electronic.
I think that's an
all-time world record.
Which means that, if
my grandmother needs
a new driver's license, She
has to log on to a computer
and go online to
actually get that.
And so we have a tradition
for being quite digital,
and also using this
as an actual thing.
If you look at something
which every single Dane has,
that's a civil registry
system, something
called the CPR system.
It's basically a number--
a personal identification
number that
is given to you within
minutes after your birth,
and it follows you
throughout your life.
And that contains
a lot of the data
that other countries are, today,
discussing whether you need
sort of a whole of
government approach,
or a universal identification
system, where you can store
medical records or
educational records,
and so on and so forth.
And that's an integral
part of the Danish society,
and I think it's also
one of the reasons
why we have a high degree of
trust in public government.
That's perhaps actually
one of the differences
between Denmark and the US.
We tend to trust the
government quite a lot.
I think, at least in the part
of the world, or part of the US
where I'm living,
in Silicon Valley,
there seems to be a
little larger trust
in the private sector
and in companies.
But the way we use that
trust in government
is that we have the system.
It hasn't been
breached or hacked yet.
And hopefully, it
will never do that.
But it actually offers a lot
of opportunities for using
this data which is available.
So I think those
two, three things
are one of the reasons why
we came up with the idea.
But the last one
being that we've
always been a small
country, an open country,
very dependent on others,
also because of our size.
So looking into how we prepare
ourselves for the future--
what will it mean
for our labor market?
What will it mean for
full global affairs?
How can we continue to
take a responsible approach
to helping other parts of the
world that are, perhaps, doing
less well than we are?
So that's the last reason why, I
think, we took this initiative.
RASMUS GREVE: And in that
vein, and our history
of using big data as a
way of the population
trusting the governments with
our data and, you know, we--
it is quite wild to
think about that.
The government
actually has access
to all your health
information, and all
your income tax information
and all these things.
Do you feel that
that's a driving force?
That the population of
Denmark says, all right.
We trust the government to
forge these relationships
with tech companies.
And this is why it's not the
US or China or France that's
gone out and done
this initiative?
CASPER KLYNGE: I
think, by the way,
we might come back to that.
Other countries are
looking at what we're doing
with quite a lot of interest.
And I think a lot
of other countries
are considering whether to
appoint tech ambassadors,
whether it will be
in Silicon Valley
or in Beijing or in
Hangzhou or somewhere else.
I think that's not
the important bit.
But the fact that
other countries
are getting
inspiration from what
we're doing, and
acknowledging that we need
to treat technology and
digital platforms in a more
systematic way, is positive.
To some extent,
it's part of my KPI
that we deliver other countries.
Also because it's super
lonely to sit out in Palo Alto
all by yourself.
I really miss the
National Day receptions,
which are such an important
part of diplomacy these days.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't, actually.
But nobody is watching, right?
So I can be completely
honest here.
RASMUS GREVE: They
will, eventually.
It's going into the blog.
CASPER KLYNGE: But I think
the trust thing is important.
But I also, to be very
honest, sitting here
in front of techies,
who understand this much
better than I do, we
have a high degree
of confidence between
the citizens of Denmark
and the public sector.
When you look at perception
data on globalization,
or where the world
is heading, the Danes
are, generally, also
quite optimistic.
They look at the future
in a positive light,
even despite global
affairs and issues
that you might
point to currently.
But I think it's
also fair to say
it doesn't take too much or
too many Facebook Cambridge
Analytica cases to perhaps
tilt that confidence.
And we spoke a little bit about
the CPR civil registry system
before.
And of course, one
of the reasons people
trust this is because
it hasn't been breached,
it hasn't been hacked.
But one could
imagine, of course,
that the public trust
in these systems
could go sour if we see
more of these big scandals.
So that's another reason
why we need a conversation
with technology companies.
And that's one of
the reasons why
we have a lot of focus,
right now, on data ethics,
also on cyber security issues.
So we make sure we protect these
systems against malign actors,
basically.
RASMUS GREVE: And I would
also say, as a comment,
working at Google--
and I've been here
for these last 9,
almost 10 years.
What's happened over
the last year has--
for the first time--
from a personal perspective,
I work on these platforms--
is that we are, all of a sudden,
on the wrong side of the trust
conversation, right?
That's kind of new for us.
It's always the governments
that the public mistrusts.
It's usually the
tech companies that
have been good beacons, and
stewards of all this data,
and all these things,
which we still are.
But it's just the-- the fact
is that many of the things
that we offer and have has
far-reaching implications
that we might not have
been able to predict.
But I can say that the
discourse, internally
in the company, is very much
what you're saying there.
We need to make sure
that we get around that.
CASPER KLYNGE:
That's good to hear.
[LAUGHTER]
RASMUS GREVE: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I guess that's why
you're here today.
It's not a, oh, tech diplomacy?
We're just going
to shut the door.
It is a thing that's
on everybody's mind.
And we can also see there's
a lot of audience here.
That's a good point, right?
I started out saying,
ask questions,
because technology can
really cover everything.
There's not a lot
of things that's
not influenced by technology.
Your water is data-driven.
Everything that is put into
it, that's tech-driven water,
whatever.
But I would say that
a fair question could
be what have been at the core
of your work the last 12 months
that you've been
a tech ambassador?
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
Well, one of the differences
between the job I have now
and some of the jobs I've
been doing previously is I
get one question all the time.
What on earth are you doing?
And what is the success criteria
for actually doing that?
And I can tell you, nobody--
I came directly from
Jakarta in Indonesia--
nobody ever asked
me the question,
what do you actually
do, and what's
the added value of having
an embassy in Indonesia,
or having an ambassador
in Indonesia?
I get that question
all the time.
And my answer is not
very sexy, but I'll
give it to nonetheless.
What we are trying to do is
basically elevate our dialogue
with the tech industry,
with the companies,
but also with
other countries and
international organizations.
It's not a coincidence we're
meeting today during the UN
General Assembly week, because
technology and digitalization
is going to be an important
topic on development,
on the future of the
multilateral systems.
But the core of what
we are trying to do,
and what my team
is trying to do,
is to offer to
Danish authorities
a formalized platform for
having a dialogue with companies
like Google, or
some of the others--
Alibaba, Tencent-- on
a wide range of topics.
And what does that mean?
It means that we're
doing exactly the same
as other embassies all
over the world, not
only Danish embassies, but US
embassies or Belgian embassies.
And that is represent Danish
authorities on whatever
topic might be relevant.
So in other words,
one day, it might
be coming soon to
Mountain View and saying,
we'd like a conversation
about data privacy.
The next day, it might be a
question of digital taxation,
because that's a
topic that is very
much on the agenda
in Europe these days.
A third day, it might
be, how could we
get access, or convince
Google to do investments
in data centers in Denmark?
And the third day, it might
be on some difficult questions
on, how do we avoid
platforms being
misused for radicalization,
extremism, or terrorism?
So that wide range of
topics goes to the core
of what we're trying to do.
I think it's important
to say that this is not
a pessimistic tech agenda.
And I'm not saying this
to be friendly to techies
in this room.
But this is really
about using and reaping
all the opportunities that
technology brings about.
And we, fundamentally,
think that technology
will do good for this world.
But we also have a
realistic view on it,
where we think we
have to work together
with Google, with others, to
make sure that we mitigate
those areas where there are real
dangers and real difficulties.
For example, on creating
global inequality
or a digital poor part of
the world, which I personally
think is going to be one
of the major challenges,
getting the
remaining 3.5 billion
people online so
they can also reap
the benefits of these issues.
But at the core of
what we're trying to do
is really this
government-to-industry
conversation.
And in that sense, what
I do was very old school.
In fact, I would argue that it's
sort of bringing diplomacy back
to its roots.
Diplomacy has always been about
putting people into hotspots
where changes were underway.
In the old days, it was
typically into war-prone areas,
or where conflict existed.
Today, it's about
putting diplomats
into the heart of
Silicon Valley so that we
can have conversations with you
guys on how we fix the world,
or we make sure that
we don't undermine
some of the key values
and institutions
that we've been working
on for a very long time.
RASMUS GREVE: Yeah.
I think--
CASPER KLYNGE: So
small, easy issues.
RASMUS GREVE: Yeah.
Small, easy issues.
But we also have to
cope with the fact
that there's something
called legislation
that you guys represent.
We must-- looking
at legislation,
which is a tool you guys
have, is a tool that
the governments--
the US, everybody has.
You can say legislation and
technology definitely does not
always move at the same speed.
And obviously, we can talk
about GDPR as an example.
Many people in here has
been involved with that.
And while it has
been in the works
for several years, when
you look at how long it
takes from just an example to
actually be put into practice.
We can also see that,
in California, they
can push the Consumer Privacy
Act through in, I guess,
two months.
That was real fast that
they do these things.
That's a part of it that's very
interesting to how legislation
and the political
agendas and all that
is not always fine-tuned.
To come up with
emerging technology,
and then we look at
what is coming up
with blockchain and AI,
when we look at decision
making in governments.
What do you feel that we--
you and I, and
everybody else here--
can do to close the gap between
technology and regulation?
And we can start saying,
what can governments do?
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
Well, a couple of different
angles on that question.
Of course, the million
dollar question,
how do we fix these issues?
Well, I think, from a
government point of view,
we have to recognize
that we are going
to be challenged over
the next couple of years,
over the next decade, because
of the pace of new technologies.
You mentioned blockchain.
I think IoT is
another good example.
And of course, machine learning
and artificial intelligence
is probably going to
transcend everything we do.
I mean, no sector will
be left untouched.
No industry will
And therefore, no government
will be left untouched.
I think, from the
industry side--
and I don't want to be
too rough on big tech.
But what I would
say is that I think
we have a shared
responsibility here.
One of the things that I
continue to argue quite a lot
is that we might not see
eye-to-eye between Europe
and the US on some
of these issues.
There has been a bit of
tech clash in Europe.
And I think, on the US
side, there has been,
perhaps, some concerns
about the direction
that Europe is taking,
GDPR being one of them.
I think anti-trust
legislation is another one.
But it doesn't change the fact
that we have to stick together
because we're still
products of the same values
that we paid a very
high price to get to.
And the conclusion of that is
that we have to work, also,
to find the right way forward.
And just to take one
example, if you'll allow me,
Rasmussen, digital taxation.
I know it's a tricky issue.
It's a tricky issue
in Europe, and I
know it's a tricky issue
also with headquarters
of tech industries.
But if you look at Europe,
technology companies
pay around half of what
traditional companies are
paying in taxes.
And you could say, well, that's
a smarter way of operating.
But for most European countries,
this is an existential issue.
Because this is what basically
undermines our ability
to pay for education,
health care, basically
to uphold the welfare state.
There are a couple of proposals
from the European Commission
currently being discussed.
I don't think
they're particularly
popular in Mountain View,
but you can correct me
if I'm wrong on that one.
But it doesn't
really change what
I think is the way
forward, and that
is that we have to work
together on finding solutions,
also on, for example,
on digital taxation.
So what I mean by
that is I think
we need to enter a
contract where we come
to the industry also
looking for advice,
looking for some suggestions on,
what is the right way forward?
Not to stifle
innovation, to make sure
that we have a pro-tech,
pro-platform environment
in Europe.
But we also expect,
from the tech industry
and from the senior
management teams,
that they help us to find
the right way forward.
It's not good enough to say
we don't like the European
Commission's proposal.
And when you then
ask the question,
so what should we do
instead, the answer
is, well, that's not
up for us to define.
I think it is, and I think
that's where we are today.
A crossroad where
we have to expect,
from the senior management
of the tech industry,
that they help us define
the right way forward,
whether it is on
digital taxation,
or whether it's on regulation,
or whether it's on legislation.
Because the absence of that is
not going to help the industry,
and it's certainly
not going to help
the governments or, in
our case, Europe, either.
So that's the way
forward, in my view.
That's what we're trying
to do with this initiative,
I believe.
RASMUS GREVE: I see it,
and I could, at some point,
say the communication is pretty
much one-way, as you're saying.
We do get engaged and
say, we don't like that.
But maybe we could build a
feedback loop, in that sense.
But yeah, that takes
time, and that's
why you're the first
tech ambassador
to start getting
these things going.
It's a legislation again.
That's the tool that
sets in one way,
and maybe there's a gap
in legislation in Europe
that needs to be
fixed, and agreed upon
by member states in
the European Union.
CASPER KLYNGE: No, absolutely.
Can I just add
one thing, Rasmus?
RASMUS GREVE: Yes, of course.
CASPER KLYNGE: I think--
I don't think I'm
revealing any state secrets
by saying that, of course,
Europe is not always
united on how we deal with
technology and digitalization,
how we deal with the big
technology companies.
There are different
views among the EU-28--
or EU-27, soon.
But what we offer-- and I think
that goes a little bit back
to one of your first
questions-- what's
the value proposition
that we bring also
to a company like Google?
Well, that is to have a
dialogue, also on the issues
we might not see eye-to-eye on.
It's also an opportunity
to begin discussing,
how do we create the
regulation of tomorrow
so it doesn't undermine
the commercial activities
of the tech industry?
Which is perfectly fine for us.
We don't have any
problems with monopolies.
We don't have any problems with
companies growing and making
money, as long as
that is not misused--
that dominant position
is not being misused.
So I think companies
like Google or Facebook,
or Alibaba and others, they
will find no better friends
than Denmark, in the sense
that we have always been light
on regulation,
but we have always
been right on regulation.
We have to make sure that we
go in where it matters, also
to protect our institutions and
democracy and human rights--
all the big stuff
which is important,
and which we fought
quite a long time for,
over several centuries.
We have to make sure we don't
undermine those institutions.
And having that discussion,
and bringing the two parties
together, I think,
is going to be
essential in the next decade.
RASMUS GREVE: And I think,
from a personal perspective,
and all that, and I
think I'm speaking
for many that it is actually a
point where we should get to.
Technology moves at such
an increasingly fast pace,
that even if you
are in it, you're
not necessarily always able
to protect the influences
it has all around.
And this is the
exponential change, right?
It is faster and
faster and faster,
Moore's law and
all these things.
And the human brain
thinks linearly,
and so does organizations.
You don't necessarily
get into that,
but we'll try and
get ahead of that.
It would be the
aspiration, in that sense,
and why you are here.
But let's try it and look
at a little bit of a wider
perspective.
Because your mandate
is actually global.
We've been talking about the
US and the European Union
and all these complicated,
dense matters that are there.
But let's talk a
little bit about where
some exciting opportunities
is out in tech diplomacy.
So your team is kind of like--
you work from Mountain
View-- you work from Silicon
Valley, sorry about that.
But you also have
a part of your team
that's situated in
Copenhagen and in Beijing.
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
RASMUS GREVE: For you,
what does it actually
mean to be an ambassador
to a global industry?
It's not just--
CASPER KLYNGE: It means having
meetings at horrible times
almost every day.
[LAUGHTER]
Because finding a common
time to have the whole team
present is basically
impossible because of the time
differences.
This is also a foreign
policy experiment.
I think it's important
to mention that.
We haven't done it before.
We don't think anybody
else has done it before,
but we think it's the right
way to look at diplomacy
in the 21st century.
That it's not only about having
one embassy to one country,
but it's, in fact, looking
at an industry or a sector
in a holistic way.
Again, I represent
the foreign ministry,
so it goes without
saying that we
are focusing on the global
aspects of new technology.
So I think if you look at
the US or the Americas,
if you look at Europe
and you look at Asia,
changes are underway.
It goes without saying that
there is a shift, or a change,
also on balance of power.
I think, when you look
into the crystal ball,
it's evident that, in Europe,
we say it will move east.
I guess, where we're sitting,
it could also move west.
But the point being that China
and other Asian countries
look as though they're
going to be using technology
as a game-changer,
also for their position
on the global scene.
It's interesting, if you look
at investments in artificial
intelligence-- the last year of
venture capital investments--
I think 30% or so went to
the US, 48% went to China,
and the rest went to the rest
of the world, which by the way,
includes the European Union.
I think it doesn't require
too much creativity
to see that that's perhaps the
contours of a new global order,
and that we might
see technology being
a driver for significant change,
also in the global scene.
I think where we're
struggling in Europe
is, of course, to have a
better focus on innovation.
We need to also build
some of the unicorns
that the US and China and Asia
is extremely good at doing.
And I think that requires us
to take a look on regulations,
on legislation.
But it also requires us
to take a look on mindsets
and, perhaps, a little
bit on access to capital
for some of these big companies.
I think Europe has
a role to play.
I know we're
sitting in New York,
but I think Europe could play
a role, in the sense of help
define the boundaries
for new technology.
I know that GDPR--
the Data Protection
and Regulation--
is not necessarily
popular everywhere.
It's not popular
everywhere in Europe,
either, with small and
medium-sized enterprises.
But it's a first attempt to
try and define the boundaries,
and to make it crystal clear
that data is something which
is also personal, something
that you can own yourself,
and that you have the right
to be forgotten further
down the road.
Is it perfect?
Perhaps not.
But it's an attempt
to try and set
some boundaries for
new technologies.
Between the Wild West of Silicon
Valley, where everything goes,
and where it's all about
building and creating.
But also the Wild
East, where you
see the utilization of new
technologies happening in,
perhaps, not an
unregulated space,
but certainly a space which
is very different than what
we're seeing in
Europe right now.
So again, from
our point of view,
from a Foreign
Ministry point of view,
this is also about looking at
where the world is going to be,
not only in five years, but
also in 15 years, or 25 years.
Because that
matters, even though
you are a very small country
at the top of Europe.
RASMUS GREVE: Yeah.
Now you're talking
about, I guess, looking--
when we talk about the
East and China and all
that, you're looking into
the private sphere, what
sort of innovation
we can find there.
But we are talking, also, a
little bit about influencing
foreign policy and
all that, which
we were talking about before.
What kind of similarities
or differences
do we see between trying to
do that in the US and Europe,
and in Asia, trying
to get in there
and see if you can
influence that.
CASPER KLYNGE: On the
foreign policy side?
RASMUS GREVE: Yes.
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
It goes without
saying that we've
been spending
quite a lot of time
with US technology
companies, to begin with.
Also, again, for
transatlantic reasons,
we think it's important
to stick together.
And what we've been
trying to do is
to use all diplomatic
tools, which
is going to have-- going
to the headquarters
to have conversations,
trying to convince,
in a gentle and nice way, the
headquarters to begin focusing
more on some of these issues.
Also, to take action
in particular areas
where we might have
issues or challenges.
That has worked well
with some companies.
Perhaps a little less
well with other companies.
Some of it is also
because of curiosity.
What is this about?
Is this TechPlomacy
initiative, is this
all about bringing the
big stick of regulation,
and trying to do damage to the
opportunities of big companies?
Well, it's not.
And once we've had
the opportunity
to explain what we're trying to
do, most companies have said,
well, we actually see
that this makes sense,
and we would like to work
with you on this agenda.
But we need more people
around the table.
We need more countries.
We need all the international
organizations around the table.
Which is, by the way,
one of the reasons
we're sitting in New York,
again, during the UN Week.
We welcome the UN Secretary
General's decision
to set up a high-level panel
on digital cooperation.
So I think that's-- and
the European Union has done
something similar under the high
representative for Mogherini.
So I think this is a trend.
We are seeing more
countries, we are
seeing international
organizations
beginning to step
up to the plate,
and focusing on digital issues
and on technology, per se.
So there are some differences.
And of course, there
are differences, also,
when you look towards China and
some of the big companies they
have there.
My prime minister is going to
meet Jack Ma later this week,
so perhaps I can
come back on Friday
and give you feedback on
how that discussion was
compared to some of the
other discussions we've had.
RASMUS GREVE: That'd be great.
[LAUGHTER]
No, actually, it is fascinating.
And you were talking about
the investments into AI
that the US is making, that
China is making, which--
we move into a decision making--
faster decision making
world, which is really--
yeah.
No, but-- I want-- and this
is my own little thing.
I always feel that that's
so interesting to look into.
For you, in 10 years,
giving everything
that we're doing with
AI and everything that--
in 10 years, how do
you think the Security
Council will look like?
CASPER KLYNGE: I
think it'll look,
more or less, as it does today.
[LAUGHTER]
It's difficult--
RASMUS GREVE: You don't think
Google will have a seat, huh?
[LAUGHTER]
CASPER KLYNGE: We
can do a sweepstake
and see where it hits.
I think it's important to say
that, although we are arguing
for a closer public-private
partnership on some
of the big issues,
they are still
a domain which should remain for
states and for nation states.
And I think the UN will remain,
or the Security Council,
will remain a forum where
states are discussing
some of the big issues.
However, I think
what we will see
is a small revolution, where
all these discussions will also
take place in the
margins of the UN
or in the margins of the
European Union, where we begin
having discussion groups,
or discussions fora,
to bring about the opportunity
to sit together with industry
and actually talk about issues,
including foreign policy
issues.
Including how do we make
sure that you guys will also
take responsibility for bringing
the next 3 billion people
online?
You will also take
responsibility
to make sure that we don't have,
again, parts of this world that
will fall behind.
Because we shouldn't forget
that this is not only
about bringing health care
or education to people
that are less
fortunate than others.
This is also about making
sure that the root causes
of extremism, or
migration flows,
that they will not
be nurtured simply
because of global inequalities.
So these are real issues.
There might be
commercial opportunities
for a company like Google.
But also, from a
government point of view,
it is incredibly important
that we work together
to try and fix some of
the inequalities that
might exist on a global level.
RASMUS GREVE: And
then, you answered
one of my next questions.
CASPER KLYNGE: I'm sorry.
RASMUS GREVE: No,
that's completely fine.
That's--
[LAUGHTER]
That's where we
should go, right?
We should meet-- instead
of the problems popping up,
you should be verbalizing them.
But we're also talking about
privacy and fake news and all
that, and where we are there,
and how we can work together.
But I do feel that that's
the future of collaboration
and the UN.
And if you can talk about
what the last 60 years to find
the Security Council, and
the end of World War II,
and where we're moving
with the Cold War,
whether that's relevant in
the next 10 years, perhaps.
But then, as we
move beyond that,
it is bigger challenges that we
will need to partner ourselves.
We cannot have the
hammer of communism,
the power of capitalism, to
solve some of those things.
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
RASMUS GREVE: Well, in
my personal opinion.
Anyways, I have two
more questions left,
and then I think I'm going
to start opening it up
to the floor for questions.
And I've been listening
to your podcasts,
and we also met last year right
when you became newly-minted.
And the one thing you did say
was that, after the first year,
your success
criteria would really
be that you weren't the first
and only tech ambassador.
How's it going out there?
CASPER KLYNGE: Relatively well,
but not exactly as good as I
hoped.
We are seeing a lot of
other countries coming up
with similar appointments.
I don't think anybody else
has been given exactly
the same title,
but I have a group
of colleagues around the
world that are dealing
with some of the same topics.
Some of them are called cyber
ambassadors, some of them
are called ambassadors
for digitalization.
Others are called ambassadors
for entrepreneurships
and startups.
But I think we will
see a wave coming
in not too distant a future.
And again, I think that would
be absolutely fantastic.
And we actually
think that this is
in the interest of everybody.
Not only governments but, in
fact, also of the industry.
It would also enable us to
take collective meetings,
so we don't have to open
the doors every time
an individual tech
ambassador comes by,
but that we can
actually begin looking
at how to cooperate together.
And perhaps I can
deliver a small teaser.
We're not ready
with it yet, but one
of the things that
my team is working on
is, in fact, to perhaps
create a coalition
of like-minded countries,
and a couple of companies
where we actually create a
forum where we can discuss
the broad range of topics
in relation to technology,
and where technology is heading.
So perhaps, soon, when we
have a conversation next year,
that will be established,
and we can talk a little bit
about the mission, and
where we see that heading.
I think that's about
what I can say today.
So stay tuned for more
information on that.
But it actually goes
to the core of what
we're trying to achieve with
the TechPlomacy initiative.
RASMUS GREVE: But
that's actually true.
It makes bigger
companies easier to--
because we're
organizations, right?
We at fault for everything that
happens, it's very top-down,
to try and say, hey, there's
something really interesting
we need to engage on here.
And sometimes it's hard
to get that bubbled up.
So the bigger you have,
the bigger the brand,
and umbrella organizations,
and we are engaging with that.
Because the UN, even, for us,
can be hard to engage with.
Or even state
departments, which I've
tried previously, in my job.
We did work very close
to the Danish state
for various things.
So that would be
a very good thing.
Again, I need to refer
back to me listening
to the podcast and all that.
By the way, it's called
"TechPlomacy Talk,"
and it's an amazing podcast,
and you should really--
Casper has fantastic
people he interviews.
CASPER KLYNGE: I paid him to
say that, just to be clear.
RASMUS GREVE: Yeah.
Get a little-- it's
on podcast [INAUDIBLE]
You can easily find it on
SoundCloud and everything.
No, it's good.
And on iTunes, right?
Yes.
CASPER KLYNGE: Sorry.
RASMUS GREVE: Yes.
That's OK.
It's an open platform.
CASPER KLYNGE: We diversified.
RASMUS GREVE: No,
it's an open platform.
It's all good.
But really, if you have any
interest in this sort of thing,
please get into that.
And if anybody has
any questions, please
get to the microphones.
But you always finish with
the question of these talks,
saying like, hey, what question
should I have asked you that I
didn't?
And what's the answer
to that question?
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
It's the poor
man's response when
you know that you're not
clever enough to come up
with a good question.
So it's a nice way to
get people to come up
with some interesting answers.
I think the question you
should have asked, Rasmussen--
I sort of indicated a
little bit the [INAUDIBLE]
is, what can you do for us?
What can Google do to support
an initiative like that?
And I think what is important is
that we experience and we see,
also publicly, a renewed
societal responsibility
from the tech industry.
I'm not only talking
about Google here,
but the industry, per se.
We need to see a societal
responsibility, which
is proportional to the kind
of influence you guys have
when you look at the platforms,
and all the new technologies
that you're rolling out.
We haven't spoken too
much about health care.
I know it's a massive
investment, also,
for a company like Google.
I think there is a
commercial dimension to this.
And that is, I think we all
are desperate to see a lot more
responsibility, a lot more
engagement, also a lot more
creativity in finding
answers to some
of these difficult questions.
So I think what
you can do for us,
which should serve Google's
own interest, or the industry's
own interest, is actually
to open the doors
and begin becoming more
comfortable with having
discussions with governments.
We're not out there to get you.
In fact, we are out
there to work with you
and help each other
solve what I think
are really timely and incredibly
important questions, not least
in this time and age.
We're talking about
democracies, we're
talking about human rights
issues, about gender equality.
We're talking about inequality
at the global scale.
These are not small issues.
These are incredibly
important issues,
regardless of whether
you work for government,
on the dark side,
or whether you work
for an upcoming tech industry,
a company like Google.
RASMUS GREVE: Duly noted,
and thank you very much.
CASPER KLYNGE: So
sign here if you--
RASMUS GREVE: Yes.
I think I'll let
somebody else do that.
But no, I think everybody
is always looking
for making collaboration.
Google has a mission,
and that is making
the world's information--
come on, help me here-- free
and universally accessible?
Exactly.
Right?
Which really ties into--
CASPER KLYNGE: I guess
you have a test when
you move into Google.
You have to be able
to answer this.
RASMUS GREVE: That's
true, but yeah, yeah.
That's our mission.
Yeah.
Now I'm getting a little bit
flustered, in that sense.
Can't even recite the mission.
But anyways, let's start with
questions for the time we have.
Let's start with the
right side microphone.
Hi.
If you could state
your name, and then--
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Gabriella.
I'm a designer here at Google.
Thank you so much for
talking to us today.
So my question is--
I'm from Mexico, where the
idea of the government knowing
everything about you is bad.
Just you don't want that.
So I'm curious,
how did you achieve
this 90% of your interactions
with citizens being digital?
Is there a lot of
infrastructure?
Do people have
computers at home,
do they all have internet?
Do they have that
internet literacy?
And the second one is, did you
have to persuade them at all,
or do they just trust you?
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
A really good question.
And thanks for posing it.
We're not-- let me
put it this way.
Of course, I acknowledge
that it's much easier
to implement systems
like that when
you have a small, homogeneous
country like Denmark.
Where the distances
are relatively small,
and where we already have a
high degree of digitalization.
But if I'm going to say it a
little bit black and white,
one of the reasons
I think we have
such a high degree
of penetration
of digital solutions
is, in fact,
because we didn't
ask the population.
This was something which
was implemented gradually.
Initially, primarily out
of efficiency reasons.
We wanted to save
resources, be more--
get more bang for the buck
in our communications,
in our service
delivery to people.
And going digital was certainly
part of that direction.
I think that discussion
has changed today,
where it's much more
about quality, not
only about efficiency.
But the honest answer is it
was gradually introduced.
And the interesting thing
was that the public sector
took the lead.
This was not something that
came from the private sector.
The public sector took the lead.
It was not incredibly popular,
neither in the private sector,
to begin with.
But people got used to it.
And today, it's actually
a competitive advantage
because Danish companies
are used to this.
They've been doing it forever.
But also, the people
are used to it.
And actually, one thing
which might be shocking
if you live in the
US is, on average, it
takes a Dane 15 minutes
to do the tax report--
the annual tax report.
15 minutes.
Because everything is
provided digitally.
You just go in and
you check the numbers.
Are they-- do they look OK?
Most people go to the end and
see, are we getting money back,
or do we need to pay some money?
But that's some
of the advantages,
and people enjoy that.
So I think the popularity
is certainly there.
And sorry, the
second question was?
AUDIENCE: Oh, did you have to--
I guess you kind of
already answered it.
Did you have to actually
persuade them to get on board?
But I think you said that
you implemented it gradually.
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah, we did.
But of course, as I
said, what I think
we had to pay attention
to was to make sure
everybody was on board.
So there is an analog
way of replying
to government questions, or to
interact with the government.
Because of course, not
everybody is online.
And I think that's
the important bit,
that you have a safety
net around those
that are not online.
But the direction
is crystal clear.
We want to have
everybody on board.
And I think, with
the next generations
coming on board, that
will be even more
natural than it is today.
But again, it is easier
in a country like Denmark
than it might be in a
big country like Mexico.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
CASPER KLYNGE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Your
Excellency, my name is Klaus.
Welcome to Google.
I'm an analyst here.
I'm also a fellow
Dane, and I'm going
to preface my first
question with saying I used
to work at your organization.
I've since switched
your nice dress shoes
with these very
comfortable sneakers.
CASPER KLYNGE: Good for
you, and condolences
about your experience before.
AUDIENCE: Oh, thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
So my first question is on
foreign relations, in general.
So Google is pretty good at
making decisions based on data,
and informing our
product development.
How do you see that
informing foreign relations?
For example, in your
own organization,
are we taking in more data
to make informed decisions?
And the second question is
more on the monopolistic nature
of a lot of these companies in
the [? neighboring ?] economy,
and regulation of the same.
So a lot of the innovation
that Google is doing
is often when we go
to the marketplace
and say, actually,
we can do better.
So take, for example,
Google Chrome.
There might be several
reasons for that.
Or Google Fiber,
where Google decided
to go out and challenge some of
the incumbents of the market.
How do you avoid regulating
some of that innovation that
also comes from big companies?
And when you do that, once you
start to meddle in the market,
how do you avoid then,
for example, saying,
well, we're going
to regulate maybe
some of the American companies
and the European companies.
But maybe the Alibabas
and Tencents of the world
would then go in and get a
bigger share of the market.
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
Super good questions.
On the first one, how do we
use data in foreign policy?
Well, I think we
don't use it enough.
And part of my mandate,
together with my team,
is also to help change the
mindset inside the government,
or inside the Foreign ministry,
in a more digital direction.
What does that
mean, in practice?
It means, for example, that
when we look at our developing
cooperation with Africa or with
Asia, we're also taking, now,
a firm view on whether
we're doing the right stuff.
Is it good to focus on delivery
of water in Tanzania, in Kenya?
Or should we, in fact,
look at infrastructure,
and building the right
competences for people
so they can, again, reap the
benefits of the digital age.
That's one area to look at it.
The other area is, of course,
to see whether we, as a delivery
mechanism, can use data in a
better way inside the Foreign
Ministry.
And last year, we--
I'm sorry I have to
name a rival company,
but it's a US rival company.
We supported a collaboration
between the Danish Refugee
Council and IBM.
And that partnership was about
using data on migration flows.
First of all, to better
predict, in Europe, where people
are coming from, what
are the reasons why
people are migrating.
But it was also to help deliver
better humanitarian efforts.
So in other words, people in
extremely difficult conditions,
and dire needs, how do we get
the right kind of assistance
to them so we don't
send out the wrong stuff
that they don't need?
And I think data is
going to be creating
a small revolution in how we
deliver those kind of services.
So we get more
bang for the buck--
so efficiency, again.
But actually, also make
a bigger difference
for the people on
the receiving end.
So I think data will play an
incredibly important role.
But as with any
other organization,
it takes a little while
to get the mindset going
in that direction.
But that's part of what
we're trying to help with.
On the other issue, I think
you point to one thing
which we're still
struggling with in Europe,
and that is, how do
we support innovation?
How do we make sure that we
don't regulate technologies
in a way that actually
we'll be shooting ourselves
in the foot in the long term?
There is a lot of focus on
antitrust and competition.
And I'll be honest
with you, to share
that when I moved
to the US last year,
and when I went to the
headquarters in Silicon Valley,
one of the first questions
was always, your Danish?
I said, yeah.
Isn't the EU commissioner
for competition--
isn't she Danish, as well?
I said, Yeah.
And they said, how does
that work together?
Because you just said this is
a tech-positive environment.
But I think-- and I told
Commissioner Vestager myself,
so I can tell this honestly.
The interesting thing
is, just in the 12 months
we've been on the
ground, I think
there has been a convergence
of view across the Atlantic
on some of these issues.
Where there is a recognition
that regulation is not
only a bad thing, as long as
we do it in the right areas,
and then leave the
other areas alone.
So I think if you look
at Commissioner Vestager,
she's gone from being persona
non grata in certain parts
of Silicon Valley,
or the Bay Area,
to become a little
bit of a rock star.
And you know things are
changing when the venture
capitalists are saying,
well, perhaps we
need to take a
look on regulation,
and we need to invest
more in companies
that have a bigger
social-corporate
responsibility.
Then things are changing.
I think that's a positive thing.
And I think that will
actually also build
better companies, and more
commercially sustainable
companies.
But I think the jury's
still out on how
we get it right in Europe.
We can't fix that,
as a small country.
But I would argue, not to be
too focused on my own country,
that we punch above our
weight on these issues.
Simply because we have the
degree of digitalization
and we have a positive
approach to technology.
So we can, hopefully,
also help make sure
that Europe moves in the
right direction on some
of these difficult questions.
But again, we need the industry
to help us to find what
the right direction.
So that's why we're
inviting everybody
for a long-term dance.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
RASMUS GREVE: And we have a
question over here, as well.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Appreciate it.
Thank you for coming and
speaking to us today.
As a veteran myself of
a similar organization--
I worked at the US government--
US e-government and IT office
while I was getting started up.
I have a great appreciation
for the opportunity
and the challenges you
have in front of you.
And you sort of answered
this a little bit,
but as you speak about the
breadth of what you're doing,
and the purview of it, I'd
imagine there are probably
some legacy pieces of the Danish
government that may not want
you meddling in their business.
How have you been able to
get the opportunity with them
to create the influence you
need to enact these things back
on homeground?
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
That's evidently an
insider's question.
You know how difficult it
is to get bureaucracies
to move in the right direction.
Well, the interesting thing is--
I come from the
Foreign Ministry,
but I would actually
argue that we
work as much on
the domestic agenda
as we do on the
foreign policy agenda.
There are numerous
activities back
home which is about
preparing Denmark
for the fourth
Industrial Revolution.
And one of the things
that we're doing
is actually linking up with
a lot of the ministries back
home, or a lot of
the authorities--
whether it's the
ministry for labor
or the ministry
for transportation,
or the ministry for health care.
And the thing we're
doing with them
is both to be a
forward-operating post
in the epicenter
of new technology.
So basically, being out
there collecting information,
doing small analysis.
Telling colleagues
back home, you better
be aware that Google
is looking at retina
scanning for diabetes patients.
That will have an
impact also on the way
we treat patients back home.
How do we prepare our
health care systems
for that kind of new
technologies coming
to a theater near us very soon?
So being that beacon out there,
bringing information back home,
I think plays an
incredibly important part
in both changing
the mindset back
home, but in fact, also
in a very practical way,
help look at is our
legislation prepared
for those opportunities?
Or are there areas where we
want to work with Google,
or other companies, to make sure
that, when you do health care,
or when you do education,
that we get it right?
So it also fits together
with our approach.
I don't know whether
you know this.
But Uber was
introduced in Denmark,
and then it was banned, I
think, more or less a year
after its introduction for a
number of different reasons.
I'm not going to say
that my office-- had
it been in existence
five years ago,
that it would have
fixed everything.
What I would argue,
though, is that I
think Uber is a pretty good
example of a new technology,
or a new platform, coming into
Europe, coming into Denmark,
where had we had a tech
ambassador at my office
a few years ago, we could have
identified that and said, well,
let's work with the
Ministry of Transportation
back home, or the
appropriate authorities,
and see what we can do.
What are the fine lines?
What are the red
lines for Denmark?
And then have a dialogue with
the headquarters over here
to make sure that it's not
introduced in the wrong way.
And I think that should be in
the interest of the companies,
but it's certainly also in the
interest of a country our size.
Did you notice how I
avoided answering exactly
how [INAUDIBLE]?
[LAUGHTER]
But anyway, good question.
AUDIENCE: A very positive
answer to, I'm sure,
other existing challenges.
But thank you.
CASPER KLYNGE: No, but
to be honest with you,
it's not always easy.
But I think, in any organization
or in any big industry,
there's always resistance
when you're trying
to do things in a new way.
We've experienced that.
But I think the
goal is so important
that we get this right
that, eventually, it
will cause a lot of
changes, both in mindsets
and also how we do business.
And we've seen this just in the
12 months we've been underway.
RASMUS GREVE: I
want to make sure we
get through all our questions.
CASPER KLYNGE: Sure.
RASMUS GREVE: I can
see people lining up.
Over here, yes?
CASPER KLYNGE: I'll be briefer.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Jimmy.
I'm a former Googler,
and my question
is, anyone who has been
paying attention to the news
has seen there's
increasing evidence
that Russia, for example,
is using technology
platforms-- whether it's
Twitter or Facebook, advertising
platforms-- to try to
influence democracies.
Do you see that these sort
of geopolitical conflicts
have a risk of increasingly
spilling over into tech?
And what would-- what's
your expectation,
or the Danish Foreign Ministry's
expectation for Google
and other tech companies' role?
As a neutral
arbiter, or would you
expect them to take
proactive measures
in these sorts of conflicts?
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
Super good question.
RASMUS GREVE: So happy
you got that question.
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah,
super good question.
And it enables me
to say that I think
we've realized that
cybersecurity issues is not
something that will go away.
In fact, it might increase
over the next couple of years,
also as we digitalize more and
more parts of our societies.
And of course, we
are-- and my government
has said this repeatedly.
We're extremely concerned about
the way Russia is operating
in the cyber security arena.
And we need to have better
defensive mechanisms,
but we also need
international collaboration
to try and mitigate
these issues.
These are not small
destructive incidents.
This is about potentially
meddling with elections,
or undermining public confidence
in institutions, et cetera.
So these are real issues that
we take extremely seriously.
We need an international
collaboration, also
to make sure that those malign
actors that are actually
performing these things,
that they are brought out
in the open, and in the
right circumstances.
That we have attribution
in that case.
But we also-- and
that's to answer
the last part of your question.
We certainly expect
the industry to take
a responsibility in this area.
And we know it's
incredibly complex,
and there is a very fine
line between meddling
with the freedom of speech
and freedom of expression.
And then, of course,
removing content
that you identify, positively,
as being not truthful
or basically based on
profiles that doesn't exist.
And I think that
dilemma is going
to be important to try and
find the silver bullet for.
It's not going to be
easy, but we're going
to put a lot of effort into it.
And we expect-- and
we are going to work
very hard to make sure the
industry also plays its part.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RASMUS GREVE: So we are at time.
However, I would like
to, if possible--
and I get an OK from the
control room back there--
to get the last few
questions through.
So over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Keira, and I actually
just joined Google New York
from Google Denmark.
So I have lived and
worked in Denmark
for about a year and a
half, and in the last 10
years, that was the 10th country
in which I lived and worked.
So what I see is that
there's actually this growing
population of people who--
they might not be
just digital nomads,
but obviously, that's
part of the group,
as well, who are in
different countries.
And obviously, they're
experiencing the digitalization
level in different
countries differently.
And what I noticed
is that, actually,
no country that I've
lived and worked in really
think, in any way,
about people like that,
who actually have their
presence beyond the country.
So I know that, obviously,
Denmark has done a lot,
and with Estonia, with
their [? e-citizenships, ?]
they're looking
at that, as well.
But I have kind of
a two-fold question.
Could you share-- is this part
of a discussion where people
are becoming more globalized,
and they're not really
looking at any single one
country as the source of truth
of their identity, or of
their digital identity?
And number two, do you feel
that you, in your position, can
you actually do
something about that?
Or are you having these
discussions in your circles,
as well?
CASPER KLYNGE: Oh, enormously
difficult question.
What I would say
is that, I think
you represent a group which is
growing in numbers these years.
I think, if you look at it
from a country point of view,
what there is renewed focus on
is that we need people like you
with skills and competences
to help drive the economy,
and build the new
technology companies.
And I can tell
you, very honestly,
that I haven't met a single
Danish tech company who
hasn't said, well, we're in
desperate need for skills
and competence that are
very difficult to find even
in Europe or in Copenhagen,
or wherever it might be--
Stockholm, Estonia,
and so on and so forth.
So I think a lot of focus will
go into that direction, both
to make sure we educate
a new generation that
has the right skill sets
to work in a digital world.
But also to make
sure that we can
attract the kind of competencies
that we need for the companies.
The problem is, of course,
it's a global competition.
When you sit in
Silicon Valley, I
don't think I've met any
company who hasn't said,
well, it's damn
difficult to find
the right engineers, or
the software engineers
that we need.
The competition is fierce.
And I think that competition
will become increasingly
global, so we also need global
solutions to those aspects.
Whether I can do anything
in that dimension-- well,
I think what we can do is
to bring back information
and knowledge that these are
discussions that are taking
place, also among the next
generation of tech-savvy people
that we would like to
attract to Denmark.
We can't offer any good
weather in Denmark.
But the city's not too bad, and
you can bike around everywhere.
So there are pros and cons.
So perhaps we need to be
better at branding them also.
Not because of the weather, but
because of the quality of life,
as well.
RASMUS GREVE: And that's
where he can pay me
back money for being able
to pitch Denmark as a tech
capital.
CASPER KLYNGE: Exactly.
Right.
RASMUS GREVE: All right.
I know we are way over time, but
last question from over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Tim.
I'm a software engineer here.
My question is,
traditionally, when
new technologies
came into space,
we generally didn't
have an ambassador.
We didn't have an ambassador
to, say, Standard Oil.
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And
traditionally, when
you wanted to get access to
technology, or to a skill set,
you would usually work
with the State Department
or whatnot of whatever country.
And through that, you'd create
economic deals or whatnot.
And that's been the
case, I guess, until now,
to some extent.
So another way of
asking the same question
is, I understand the
initiative of trying
to outreach to
the tech industry,
but can you give me an idea of
what's the urgency coming from,
to some extent?
CASPER KLYNGE: Yeah.
Really a relevant question.
And perhaps I can
begin by giving you
an example of the
kind of critique
that we've been faced
with in the first year.
It's quite often that
we are being asked,
so are you now putting
companies before countries?
So in other words,
is this elevating
Google to a de facto state
without having democracies
below it and all of that?
And my reply to that,
or our reply to that,
is always, well,
this is, in fact,
about trying to protect the role
of states in future governance.
Because I think
governance is going
to come under a lot of threat,
or face a lot of challenges,
because of the kind of
platforms that you guys are
building and rolling out.
It doesn't respect
the national borders
as, perhaps, some of the
old industries would.
But I think the real--
the pertinent part
of your question
is, why is it
different now than it
was 50 years ago, when the oil
industry began to roll out?
And that, I think, is
because of the pace.
So I do think that--
I don't want to
call it exponential,
but I think what we're
seeing is incredibly
fast-paced of the new
platforms being rolled out.
The way that
technology basically
penetrates everything we do--
all sectors.
It doesn't matter whether
you're in construction
or whether you're
in health care,
technology is going to be
a game-changer, potentially
within a very short time span.
So I think that's the reason
why we think time is ripe.
And it is something
different than oil.
I think data is not
a finite resource.
So you will continue to
expand and build on that,
and it gives enormous
opportunities.
And it might also challenge
a country like Denmark,
or the European Union, or
the United Nations in a more
profound way than
what we've seen
with some previous technologies.
So that's at least
our argumentation,
that this is different.
It feels different.
And therefore, we need a
different reply or response
to that.
And that reply or
response, in our case,
is part of TechPlomacy, and
what TechPlomacy is here to do.
RASMUS GREVE: OK.
Well, thank you.
A billion thank you.
Everybody, if you could
give a hand to Casper.
CASPER KLYNGE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]